a black architect who has left his mark
on Las Vegas nicknamed the architect of
the Stars Paul Revere Williams is now
being recognized for his legacy Joshua
peguero Joins us live in The Newsroom
with a closer look at today's
Proclamation honoring him Joshua born in
Los Angeles in 1894 Paul Revere Williams
designed homes for celebrities like
Frank Sinatra and Carrie gray yeah it's
his projects in Nevada that have been
most impactful in not only shaping his
legacy but Modern Day Las Vegas as well
and it was not just him being architect
to the Stars it was also making sure
that everyone enjoyed the comfort of a
home all tocioeconomic levels all walks
of life Williams knew in high school he
wanted to be an architect however it was
a career that seemed Out Of Reach for a
black man in the early 1900s still he
pressed on some of his techniques
included learning how to draw upside
down so that he would not have to worry
about making his client feel at an ease
Williams became the first black member
of the American Institute of Architects
in 1923 and was the first black
architect working west of the
Mississippi currently less than five
percent of registered Architects are
persons of color he was under recognized
for all of his career and it wasn't
until several years after his death that
he was awarded the gold medal by the AIA
which is one of the highest honors at
that organization can do
it's only fitting that his Proclamation
was held at the neon Museum formerly the
La Concha Motel which he designed the
neon museum is absolutely about
preserving history we tell the stories
of Las Vegas through the signage that we
have here some of his other designs
include the guardian angels Cathedral
and Berkeley Square Jonna Ireland spent
18 months photographing Williams's
designs for an art exhibition here in
Nevada I've noticed that buildings like
the La Concha like the guardian angel
Cathedral are sort of more modern and
make more use of modern materials
now Williams designed more than 2500
buildings around the world a large
number in Southern California you can
view an exhibition of Paul Revere
Williams's work at the Nevada State
Museum reporting live in The Newsroom
Joshua peguero eight news now